[Musique]
1995 cette parole de gisèle halimi
résonne tristement avec l'actualité moi
je crois que plus que jamais plus pour
les femmes que pour d'autres rien n'est
jamais acquis aux états unis la cour
suprême a révoqué le droit à
l'avortement en france l'avocate gisèle
halimi a été une combattante acharnée du
droit ali l'egypte ne sera qu'un corps
fonctionne un coeur une
sensibilité une intelligence une
histoire
1971 gisèle halimi est la seule avocate
signataires du manifeste des 343 à
l'époque l'ibg est illégal en france la
pétition appelle à sa légalisation la
vérité c'est que toutes les femmes
avortent y compris les femmes de députés
et les maîtresses des ministres et tout
le monde soit ils ne le disent pas et
nous lisons et moi je les dis je crois
un mouillage nous avons été les premiers
en
1972 le procès très médiatisé de bobigny
débutent sur le banc des accusés une
mineure marie claire chevallier jugé
pour avoir avorté après un violent
pour avoir avorté la jeune femme risque
jusqu'à deux ans de prison et 20 mille
francs d'amendé gisèle halimi la défense
et obtient sa relaxe au delà de défendre
les victimes l'avocate veut aller plus
loin elle veut changer la loi je crois
que les juges ont été troublés par ce
débat qui a été fait est que il faut
dire ils n'ont pas fait ce sur le
regrette personnellement je les engagés
à faire le pape saut qualitatif prendre
la responsabilité c'est leur droit et
c'est leur devoir c'est aux juges de
changer la loi et d'indiquer qu'elle ne
peut plus attractif et 1975 l'appel est
entendu la loi veil et beauté lives et
gd pénalisés une victoire pour gisèle
halimi ce qui n'empêche pas de continuer
son combat sans relâche octobre 1982
celle qui est devenue députée manifeste
pour le remboursement de l'ibg et tacle
ses opposants sur l'art bataille un peu
une bataille d'arrière garde deux fois
n'a rien gardel et et d'arrière garde
quand elle voulait empêcher les femmes
de choisir le moment de la maternité
elle est deux fois plus d'arrière garde
quand qui veulent les empêcher d'avoir
le droit remboursement deux mois plus
tard nouvelle avancée lives et j'ai
remboursé grâce à la loi roudy tout au
long de sa vie gisèle ennemis continuera
de défendre les droits des femmes elle
est morte le 28 juillet 2020 à l'âge de
93 ans
[Musique]